.
AS IF WE DON'T HAVE ENOUGH
PROBLEMS COME UP WITH THE BORDE
CRISIS INFLATION, AND CRIME ALL
RAGING, THE PRESIDENT IS NOW
SCARING AMERICANS WITH TALK OF
THE END OF THE WORLD.
BIDEN WARMING OF ARMAGEDDON IF
VLADIMIR USES A TACTICAL NUCLEA
WEAPON TO TRY TO WIN THE WAR ON
UKRAINE SAYING WE HAVE NOT FACE
THE PROSPECT OF SINCE AT THE
CUBAN MISSILE CRISIS PARADE WE
HAVE GOT A GUY I KNOW FAIRLY
WELL HE IS NOT JOKING WHEN HE
TALKS ABOUT POTENTIAL USE OF
TACTICAL NUCLEAR WEAPONS OR
BIOLOGICAL OR CHEMICAL WEAPONS
BECAUSE HIS MILITARY IS AS YOU
MIGHT SAY SIGNIFICANTLY
UNDERPERFORMING.
YOU WOULD THINK, WITH SUCH AN
ALARMING STATEMENT, THE
PRESIDENT WOULD BE READY TO
ANSWER QUESTIONS AND ASSURE
AMERICANS, BUT LOOK WHAT HE DID
INSTEAD.
LITERALLY, RUNNING AWAY.
LAWMAKERS OUR TAKING NOTES OF
HIS WEAKNESS ON THE WORLD STAGE.
>> ANTI- AMERICAN DICTATORS
AROUND THE WORLD WILL SMELT THA
WEAKNESS GET THEY SEE A WEEK
BIDEN ADMINISTRATION.
>> RIGHT NOW WE HAVE A PRESIDEN
WHO IS VERY WEAK AND ABROAD AND
AT HOME, AND HE'S BROUGHT IT TO
HIMSELF BECAUSE OF HIS POLICIES.
>> HE HAS ALSO PUT AMERICA IN A
WEAKER POSITION, HE THREATENED
OUR SECURITY BY MAKING US
DEPENDENT ON OTHER NATIONS.
GET THIS AUDIS AND THEIR FRIEND
IN THE UNITED ARAB EMIRATES
BELIEVE THAT THEY CAN DO
WHATEVER THEY WANT TO THE UNITE
STATES.
>> THERE YOU HAVE IT, I WILL GO
TO YOU FIRST,.
>> HALEY, WELCOME.
WHY NOW, WHY NOW ARMAGEDDON, I
KNOW THAT PUTIN FIRST MENTIONS
BELIEVED IT WAS IN MARCH OF THI
YEAR THE POSSIBILITY OF USING
NUCLEAR WEAPONS.
>> YOU KNOW, WHAT'S INTERESTING
TO ME IS IT SO UNPRODUCTIVE.
EVERY TIME HE SPEAKS IT'S JUST
UNPRODUCTIVE BECAUSE ON ONE SID
YOU'RE PUTTING FEAR IN AMERICAN
WHICH IS NOT HELPFUL, AND IT
REALLY QUESTIONS HIS LEADERSHIP.
ON THE OUTSIDE, IF HE KNOWS
PUTIN SO WELCOMING HE WOULD KNO
HE SHOULDN'T BE SAYING THIS IS
ARMAGEDDON BECAUSE PUTIN IS
HEARING THAT.
WHAT HE NEEDS TO DO IS HAVE
STRONG BOLD LEADERSHIP, HE NEED
TO SAY LOOK, IF YOU DO ANYTHING
THERE WILL BE HELL TO PAY.
HE NEEDS TO REMIND CHINA AND
IRAN ARE YOU SUPPORTING THIS
CONVERSATION AND HE NEEDS TO
STRAY STRONG AND WHAT WE HAVE.
OUR MILITARY CAN HANDLE THIS.
WHAT HE NEEDS TO DO IS
HAVE DETERRENCE WHEN PRESIDENT
TRUMP WAS IN OFFICE YOU DIDN'T
SEE THESE DICTATORS DOING THIS
BECAUSE THERE WASN'T A WEAKNESS
THAT WE'RE SEEING TODAY.
>> JESSE, TO THAT POINT, WHEN
BIDEN STARTS TALKING ABOUT
ARMAGEDDON, AND YOU'VE GOT
RUSSIA NOW WHICH IS AS FAR AS
I'M CONCERNED, PRETTY ELITE
POSITION AS HE IS CLOSING IN
UKRAINE.
HIS FORCES ARE BEING DRAFTED OR
FORCED TO FIGHT.
PEOPLE ARE TRYING TO GET OUT OF
RUSSIA, AND WE LIKE BUILD HIM U
AS THIS NUCLEAR POWER.
>> HAVE TO KEEP ALSO THE COUNTR
CALM IN TIMES LIKE THIS RIGHT
FDR DID IT, JFK DID IT, BUSH DI
AFTER 9/11, TRUMP DID IT DURING
COVID 19.
CAN YOU IMAGINE IF BIDEN HAD PU
IN CHARGE IN IT IS A VERY
FRAGILE TIME AND THE UNITED
STATES.
WE HAVE JUST RECOVERED FROM THI
PANDEMIC, PEOPLE ARE ANXIOUS
COMING OF A RECESSION.
AN OPEN BORDER ENDOCRINE WAY.
YOU CAN'T BE THROWING AROUND
WORDS THAT TRIGGER PEOPLE.
YOU DON'T HAVE A CEO GO ON AN
EARNINGS CALL AND SAY IT'S A
PONZI SCHEME, YOU JUST DON'T DO
THAT.
MY WIFE, IF WE WENT OUT TO
DINNER WOULDN'T JUST BRING UP
HER EX-BOYFRIEND I WOULD BE OUT
OF THERE.
YOU DON'T GO TO SAN FRANCISCO I
SCREAM MAKE AMERICA GREAT AGAIN
TRADE YOU HAVE TO KNOW THE AND
SAY THE RIGHT THING.
HE ALWAYS SAY THESE THINGS AT
FUNDRAISERS.
HE SAID THE SEMIPRECIOUS THING
AT THE FUNDRAISER IN NUCLEAR
ARMAGEDDON AT THE FUNDRAISER.
HE HAS ALWAYS FELT INADEQUATE
AND THAT IS WHY HE'S ALWAYS
BLUSTERING ABOUT HIS PUSH-UPS
AND HOW GREAT OF TEST CARS HE
GOT IN COLLEGE PRETTY KIND OF
OVER PERFORMED IN FRONT OF
DONORS TO TRY TO MAKE THEM FEEL
LIKE THIS OR THAT.
IT USUALLY BACKFIRES BIRD FORGE
ABOUT WHAT HE SAYS, LOOK AT WHA
HE'S DONE PREVIOUS CARTELS
RUNNING THE SOUTHERN BORDER.
THERE IS ELION, THIS AUDIS JUST
TURN THEIR BACKS TO US, SO YOU
CAN'T THEN DROP THIS BOMB
RHETORICALLY AND THEN RUN AWAY
TO MARINE ONE ACROSS THE LAWN
WHILE THE MEDIA IS LIKE CAN YOU
CLEAR THIS UP A LITTLE BIT, MR.
PRESIDENT?
HE'S JUST NOT SMART ENOUGH TO B
THE PRESIDENT WHICH WOULD BE
FINE UNDER NORMAL CIRCUMSTANCES
BUT KAMALA IS THAT NUMBER TOO.
>> WHAT WOULD YOU SAY, DOESN'T
PRESIDENT BIDEN HIMSELF CREATES
THE CIRCUMSTANCE SO WHEN JESSE
TALK IS ABOUT IF THIS WERE A
TRUMP ADMINISTRATION OR IF IT
WERE OUR RONALD REAGAN
ADMINISTRATION, THIS KIND OF
THING, YOU WOULDN'T BE SEEING A
LOT OF THIS.
>> TO BE FAIR, HE HAS CLARIFIED
THAT HE IS NOT JOKING.
HE HAS BEEN VERY SERIOUS.
VLADIMIR PUTIN IS NOT JOKING.
I'M GLAD TO KNOW THIS IS A
SERIOUS ISSUE.
CAN YOU IMAGINE THAT NUCLEAR
DIPLOMATIC TALKS.
I MAY LAUNCH THE NUKES, IT'S
LIKE THAT PERSON ALWAYS SAYS TO
BE HONEST, I DON'T LIKE HOW YOU
LEAD WITH THAT, WHY DON'T YOU
JUST ALL BE HONEST.
IN ORDER TO CALM THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE WOULD BE ENLIGHTENED.
THEY NEED TO BE INFORMED, THEY
CAN'T BE KEPT IN A STATE OF
CONSTANT CONFUSION.
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE HAVE BEEN
PROPAGANDIZED, THEY HAVE NOT
BEEN TOLD THE TRUTH ON ALMOST
ANYTHING.
NOW YOU HAVE HIM TALKING ABOUT
THIS IS ALL SLOPPY, IT IS ALL
HALF-TRUTH FOR IT AND THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE AND MY
ESTIMATION WILL BE GO TO WAR
DESERVE TO HAVE A SAY AND THE
ISSUE.
IF WE ARE GOING TO TRADE UP TWO
LINES, I WOULD LIKE IT BE DONE
DEMOCRATICALLY WHICH MEANS WE
NEED TO BE TOLD THE TRUTH ON
ISSUES, PARTICULARLY WHEN IT
COMES TO NATIONAL SECURITY AND
WE AREN'T GETTING EVEN
HALF-TRUTH ON WHAT'S GOING ON I
UKRAINE AND RUSSIA.
GET YOU KNOW, WITH OPEC DECIDIN
THEY WERE GOING TO PROVIDE THE
OIL THAT APPARENTLY BIDEN WAS
PLANNING ON, THAT THEY WERE
GOING TO CUT BACK ON THEIR OIL
PRODUCTION, THE PRESIDENT IS
LOOKING TO VENEZUELA, HE'S NOT
LOOKING TO DOMESTIC PRODUCTION.
>> THAT IS, I GUESS YOU COULD
QUESTION THE JUDGMENT ON THAT
FRED SAUDI ARABIA IS RUN BY A
FAMILY OF SNAKES.
I THINK THEY'RE ALL BEARING THE
LEAD, ASK VLADIMIR PUTIN IF HE
THINKS JOE BIDEN IS PROJECTING
WEAKNESS, HIS TROOPS ARE BEING
KILLED BY OUR DRONES COME ABOUT
ARTILLERY, BY OUR MISSILES,
UKRAINE IS WINNING THIS WAR AND
WHAT HE SAID IS ABSOLUTELY, THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE SHOULD
UNDERSTAND THE STAKES, THIS IS
VLADIMIR PUTIN, RANTING AND
RAVING ABOUT USING NUCLEAR
WEAPONS.
HE IS CORNERED, HE AS BLEEDING,
HE IS HUMILIATED, HIS ARMY IS
CRUMBLING RIGHT IN FRONT OF HIM.
REMEMBER THE MOVIES, THERE HAD
BEEN SWEEP THROUGH UKRAINE INTO
WEEKS OR THREE DAYS, WHATEVER I
IS.
AND HERE IS UKRAINE, THEY HAVE
HUMILIATED RUSSIA, RUSSIA IS
DANGEROUS BECAUSE IT IS WOUNDED
AND I FEAR, YOU PLAN YOUR LIFE,
YOU HAVE YOUR FAMILY IN YOUR
GRANDCHILDREN AND YOU BUILD YOU
HOUSE AND YOU HAVE A FUTURE, AN
THEN THIS NUT JOB IS TALKING
ABOUT USING NUCLEAR WEAPONS IN
WERE POINTING BLAME AT OUR
PRESIDENT WHEN IT'S THE
PRESIDENT OF RUSSIA COLLECTS.
>> THAT MEANS BOTH SIDES GET
HITS, WE ALL GET HIT.
>> BOTH UNITED STATES AND RUSSI
COLLECTS READ HIS BOOK, NEVER.
ONE TACTICAL WEAPON.
AND THEN THE OTHER ONE HAS A
TACTICAL NUCLEAR WEAPON, IT'S 1
PERCENT MORE THAN THE OTHER
GUY HAS TO GET EVERYBODY KNOWS
THAT, BUT THE POINT IS SAUDI
ARABIA COULD BE A COUNTRY OF
SNAKES, PUTIN CAN BE CRAZY, BUT
WE'VE GOT A PRESIDENT WHO IS
REACTING LIKE CRAZY AS OPPOSED
TO REACTING LIKE A DIGNIFIED
LEADER AT THE GREATEST COUNTRY
AT ON EARTH.
>> LOOK AT THE UKRAINE ARMY
PARROT.
>> HIS WORDS NEED TO EXEMPLIFY
THAT, WHAT HE'S DOING IS GAS
LIGHTING INSTEAD OF KEEPING
PEOPLE CALM.
YES WERE STRONG, YES WE WILL
CONTROL THAT, LET THE PEOPLE
FEEL THAT AND LET THEM KNOW THA
PERKY IF WE ARE ON THE VERGE OF
WHAT YOU DESCRIBE A HOPE WE HAV
SOME CLARITY AND LEADERSHI